[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening i'm pierce morgan
uncensored now people often tell me
there's no such thing as cancer culture
it doesn't exist
it's in my head
but it does exist it's very real
it involves delusional mobs who shame
abuse and vilify anyone who dares share
an opinion that doesn't conform to their
own narrow world view and here's a
perfect example of what i'm talking
about macy gray
you might recall that last week the
award-winning singer appeared on this
show and i asked her a very simple
question
if i asked you what a woman is what
would you say
i would say a human being with uh boobs
how are you to start there
yeah i mean the dictionary is quite
straightforward it just looks like an
adult right i will say this and
everybody's gonna hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
if you want me to call you or her i will
because that's what you want but that
doesn't make you a woman just because i
call you or her and just because you got
a surgery
well that was very clearly macy gray's
honestly held opinions what she actually
thinks but i warned her that she would
face a backlash and so she did in fact
the retribution was as vile as it was
predictable she was bombarded with
torrents and vicious abuse online and
branded an ignorant bigot and a
transphobe
rolling stone magazine to their shame
called her hateful before hysterically
claiming her rhetoric could have deadly
consequences now remember what macy
gray's crime was
she just said that a woman is a human
being with boobs and a vagina
yeah that apparently will spark deadly
consequences
harry potter author jk rowling one of
the very few public figures who has the
nerve to face down this noxious mob came
to her defense and quit she would buy
macy gray's back catalogue
macy gray herself initially stood by her
right to the opinion she expressed
posting this all of you threatening and
calling me names because i said
something you don't agree with be
whatever you want to be and bleep off
well good for her but unfortunately her
resolve didn't last very long
sadly the mob rules
and their abuse intensified
and macy eventually caved just one day
later she went on nbc's today program in
america to issue effectively a groveling
mia culpa
you were on the piers morgan show and
there was a question about trans women
i i think that if you
in your heart feel that that's what you
are then that's what you are regardless
of what anybody says
or thinks but yeah i've i've learned a
lot absolutely and i'm glad i did
have you may see what have you really
learned other than the mob rules that's
the way it works these days isn't it you
pander to the white brigade or you'd be
damned forever and for those people i
think this is all trivial cultural stuff
a peculiar obsession of people who spend
too much time on twitter we'll take a
look at this post from jk rowling
yesterday when she talked about the
impact that has had on her this canceled
culture
endless death and rape threats threats
of loss of livelihood employers targeted
physical harassment family address
posted online with picture of bomb
making manual aren't mean comments
if you don't yet understand what happens
to women who stand up on this issue back
off
that's happened to her it's happened to
many other women who've tried to stand
up for women's rights
that's why this is so serious it's why
women are scared to stand up for women
it's why macy gray has backed down
they're bullied and abused until they
cave
and this is what these so-called
inclusive be kind liberals are like in
real life here's a clip from a trans
pride parade in london on saturday
[Applause]
lovely people let's be clear i've always
stood up for trans rights loudly and
proudly i believe trans people are
entitled to fairness and quality as much
as i am
but still this poison posse delights in
falsely calling me a transphobe
well phobia means fear and i'm
definitely not scared of this dumb mob
anything i'm afraid of living in a
society where awful people like this
think they can bully and spew their
toxic hate and abuse towards anyone who
disagrees with them
what macy gray said to me is what she
feels it's her honestly held opinion
what she said to nbc
is what happens when a public figure is
cowed into submission and that is a
tragedy in any democracy
it's time we stopped bowing to this mob
it's time we took on the mob and stopped
them
bullying people like macy gray
basically
let me talk to you about a furore that
you're involved in last year because i
found it very interesting the way the
debate played out you wrote an op-ed for
market watch yes a year ago actually in
which you said that the american flag no
longer represents democracy and freedom
you wanted it changed
why
uh
well i i just think that uh it's it's a
it's like you know in a general thing
it's just a new day it's time to you
know you reboot the constitution the
flag all the all the old standards you
know that that our our ancestors lived
by you know were right for for the time
they lived in but we're in a different
time you know so um
so the flag is uh so in the states you
know to me what the states do best
is diversity it's culture you know what
i mean without culture in america you
really don't have much going on you know
you have you know i don't know amazon
like what do you have if you don't have
color in the states i mean i agree with
that what i would say to you is though
that
it's such a divisive issue things like
the flag do you not think there's a
danger i'm interested in what how you
feel a year on from that debate you got
hammered obviously by a lot of people a
lot of americans were outraged others
thought you raised an interesting point
in a way it wasn't that dissimilar to
what colin kaepernick went through with
the protests that he was doing some
agreed with him others were furious do
you have any regrets about the what you
said about the flag
no in fact i'm excited to bring it up
again because i i think it's more
important now what what i want to do is
is more important now it's just
messaging it's just
it's just like if you if you
so my idea was to make the stars
the colors of all of us so they start
representing you one represent me one
representing everybody in the room right
so that way you look up to the flag and
you feel welcome you feel included you
feel like you belong there why does okay
let me play devil's advocate yeah which
is
i think the american flags are fantastic
flag i love my flag here too the english
flag the uk flag that i love these flags
to me they're not about
making any kind of diverse point they're
just great flags and if i was an
american most americans are spoken to
about this they say
that there are other ways to celebrate
diversity juneteenth is one right right
there are other ways to do this why go
after such a
powerful emblem of the united states of
america when it causes the whole debate
actually a lot of disunity
well because you like it because that's
that's the only one you know just like
like um
whenever the flag was was was
conceptualized they
they made it based off what was going on
during that time which was a war that's
another thing we celebrate
a flag that represents war i actually
have an american flag on my office wall
at home yeah
i think we've got a we've got a picture
of it
um i think i look that's my office wall
uh in london
uh i look at that every day uh it's
actually quite a unique one 34 stars yes
which means it was actually the flag
from the civil war period when lincoln
was president and that's the only flag
that was in use during lincoln's
presidency and i bought it at an auction
because america's been a large part of
my life and i i find it a stirring
emblem but i never look at it and think
well that's about
white people or you know white power
over black people or that's attacking
diversity or it could be more diverse i
just think it's such a magnificent
emblem now i'm white so i might think
that
well it's not it's not that it's about
white people it's it's just that our
everything is different than when
lincoln was president so and whoever
designed that flag designed it for that
day
so i'm just saying what's wrong with the
new flag what's wrong with
representing where where we are now like
we no longer have 34 states right so
so they made one with 50 cents well then
they changed the flag over the years
that's true
when you got kicked back on this yeah
did it surprise you how ferocious some
of it was did you mine did you expect it
no i didn't expect it i thought people
would agree with me i thought people
like yeah let's let's do a new flag
i don't know it's kind of an art project
it's just like what well i don't see why
not that's my thing i don't i don't get
i understand you want to hold on to
tradition and and like you you you went
to an auction so it's probably rare and
beautiful i don't know
but but there's no reason
we we're just not that we're not back
where we were we had 34 states
on no level do you i mean given the
backlash you got do you wish you hadn't
made the stand in the way that you did
or not
no i i really want to bring it up again
i really want to push like if i didn't
won't do it i really want to hit up
who's ever next do you feel because
around the time you did this george
floyd was murdered
by a police officer
i i felt the whole world reacted in the
most extraordinary way to that moment
and quite rightly because the video was
horrendous
of what happened to him
do you feel the world has changed for
the better in the last year because of
that atrocity
in what way
do you feel that more people are aware
of racial injustice of racial equality
do you feel like they're taking the knee
which went around the world
like wildfire especially after george
floyd was killed do you feel that that
all helps or are these just
token things which don't actually make
any tangible difference
um i i think it made a lot of people
aware i think when it comes to
changing someone's view on race or
people
uh that's that's more than a one event
that's not that's
you know that's growing up that's
parenting that's where you go to school
that's what neighborhood you live in
there's a lot that goes into how you
feel about
people that aren't like you you know
what i mean did you feel that america is
more or less racist than when you grew
up
um
it's definitely not as bad you know
i was born in the 60s so i don't
understand racism be honest with you i i
like i get like i'm sitting here with
you
and we're different you know what i mean
and there might be things that i i would
be i wouldn't want to say in front of
you that i might say in front of my
friends of color and vice versa
but like to hate someone or want to kill
someone or
hold somebody down because of what they
look like i don't i don't understand i
mean i completely agree i think i think
most people would completely agree with
that i do think racism is a minority
fortunately in almost every country and
particularly america and britain i don't
think it's it by any means a popular
thing but it exists
and it's the it's what's the best way to
tackle it what's the best way to get rid
of it how do you make people who are
racist
rethink the way they are it's hard
um
i think everybody just has to let it go
you have to let go of
needing to be better than than everyone
else you have to let go of
of of your hang-ups about slavery you
have to let go of your hang-ups about
superiority you have to
you know it's very personal how you feel
about other people you know
like we could have a conversation about
how you feel about women you know and
then there would be so many things that
that went into that you know i mean
we're in an era now basically you can't
most public figures are too terrified to
even say what they think a woman is i
know i mean if i asked you what a woman
is what would you say
i would say a human being with uh boobs
how are you to start there yeah i mean
the dictionary is quite straightforward
it just
adult female right
now a lot of people yeah see that's now
that's a little getting confusing the
whole
day that's good that's good and i'm not
sure why really it's it's a bit like
this whole issue of transgenders in
sport
i support all trans rights to fairness
and equality
but not where you have people born to
obvious physical superior bodies
transitioning and then thrashing the
women at the sport i totally agree and i
i will say this and everybody's going to
hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact like if you want
me to call you or her i will because
that's what you want but that doesn't
make you a woman just cause i call you
or her and just because you got a
surgery because people do feel feel that
there's biological sex and then there's
gender identity that you can identify as
whatever you like
right that's the freedom we live in but
actually you can't change the mechanics
of biological sex they are what they are
well just every like women go through
just a completely unique experience
and and surgery or you know finding
yourself doesn't doesn't change that you
know being a a little girl is a whole
epic book you know
and and you can't you can't have that
just because you want to be a woman i
mean you know when people like jk
rowling have said this
they get attacked they get abused
the council culture mob comes from me
she gets called and she gets called
transphobic and so on you might get the
same for saying it but it's the truth
i'm not i i
and i don't think you should be called
transphobic just because you don't agree
with you know i i just there's a lot of
you know
judgment and throwing you know stones at
people for just saying what it is you
know what i mean
you have hung out with some very
interesting people in your time yeah
prince was one of them you sat in a dark
room
he called me onto his room the lights
were out which was weird and you talked
for two hours in this dark room yeah and
he gave you a great bit of advice do you
remember it
yes he said uh just remember it's not
about you what do you mean by that
well you know i i didn't know what it
meant at first so like maybe last year i
finally got it and he was just saying uh
that as an artist is about what you give
what you how you make your fans feel
it's not about you like it's like you
say you like stevie wonder like you'll
sit and listen to his records all day
but do you want to sit with stevie
wonder all day
um what's the answer i would you will i
love stevie wonder like you'd want him
to move into your house
i would love that i actually i actually
use stevie wonder
to propose marriage to my wife true
story yeah but the award steven he
actually actually videotaped a proposal
on video which i then played my wife and
she said yeah so i i owe stevie
everything okay so that's a bad example
so like yeah he can move in in fact he
ought to move in yeah totally okay what
about like uh
what about me what if i just move into
your house i think we get on great
actually i think so actually
another bad example
well you know what i mean though i don't
i think i know what prince was getting
at i don't know what you mean um you
also went over dinner with elton john
yes and the bill came to three thousand
dollars there's more than that it's
about three thousand something and you
had no idea that it was even possible to
spend that in a restaurant not at the
time you know not not then i had never
seen a bill that but now you're a
superstar yeah now come on you've you've
had a few dinners like this right yeah
what's the most you've now spent on
dinner on a dinner
gosh about that i don't know maybe three
four
not not my did you ever think when you
were growing up macy one day i'm going
to be splashing four grand no i still
think that's ridiculous
but uh that was what i remembered about
dinner with him and and i remember his
face when they when the when the bill
coming because he didn't was no big deal
he didn't even look at it and is that
your face now when you get a bill like
that no my face still goes what and i
still look at that
i still look at all the things we
ordered you know trying to get things
taken off
i read recently that you're you're
looking for love
well you know that's that's that's
subjective that's you know
that that could mean a lot of things
what what did you mean by it what did i
mean i don't know
i don't know you know i haven't been in
a relationship in a while and i've kind
of pictured myself uh you know
doing all that right now because it's a
lot of work and i don't see it yet but
i'm thinking when i do i'm i'm just
gonna have a an audition
really
yeah i'm just gonna like have a cattle
call and i get to shoot
did i say that wrong i have a man called
a cattle call yeah i'll pick the ones
you know a lot of balls turn up is that
the idea
and then i'll interview them
and then i'll and
just to give them a bit of help before
they join the queue and it'll be a i'm
sure a very extensive line but
what advice would you give them about
the kind of man you're looking for
oh gosh
see that's that's a long
okay let me think
well you know just not to be corny but
there's energy you know there's
connection there's like you look at
someone and you you know
it's that thing
energy yes energy you know you're
comfortable with someone told small do
you care
yeah how tall are you six one oh plenty
of energy you're married
she'll probably she'll probably trade me
she's probably watching
but no
but
but uh yeah definitely tall because i'm
tom 5 11. how many how many times have
you actually been properly in love in
your life do you think
well i've been married twice so that's
two plus maybe
two more
four times tops oprah told me three
times she'd be
yes it's it's difficult yeah to get to
go there you know well hard to be also
when you're as successful as you are
thank you and you're famous thank you
and you're doing all this and you're
being basically great it's hard to then
have a human relationship right where
you can i guess completely trust people
uh no i don't i don't have i'm not a big
i don't trust and i don't really worry
about that i just uh it's just a comfort
thing for me you know who i can sit with
and then be myself at least you know
most of the time when you came out with
your criticism of the american flag you
did also i think make it clear that you
were proud to be an american very i
loved by the country probably more than
most of the people who criticize me
right yeah i was going to ask you that
no i love my country i'm proud of my
country
i'm proud of where i'm from of you know
being a woman being black i love
everybody i can honestly say i love
everybody and if i could have the power
to let you relive one moment in your
entire
life yeah
outside of having your kids and getting
married what would you choose
boy
let's see
there's days in the week when i lay in
my bed in my underwear and i switch
channels and i don't have any and i'm
not worried about anything and they're
the best those are the best
and i just go through my channels and i
find something else i don't have to get
up and go to piers morgan i'm sorry i
can just lie here
those are the best moments
do you sing when you're on your own you
just suddenly let rip
uh i do you know i do i do start singing
yeah sometimes because i'm still like i
said working on my voice i'm trying to
get to a thing you know that i'm working
on i mean i mean if i was to go do you
know could you let rip or something oh
okay what do you want to hear
try i try
pierce morgan is the best
that's not amazing great come on that
was great give me a bit of my try girl
that's that's what i'm working on okay
oh i try yeah well i have a new record
out person it's way it's way better no
that could be a bit of the new one
oh the new one okay so the new one goes
um
so i have a song called uh every night
but you got it here
that should actually be the the theme
it's out now yeah i know that yeah
from the new album the reset
congratulations
and then i have a song called thinking
of you because um how's it going
because ah um
i am drinking and i am thinking of you
that's it and were you thinking of me
when you signed it totally
[Laughter]
absolutely macy it's great to see you uh
the new album the reset is on uh
released on july 8th the new single
every night is out now you just finished
your uk tour and you're on your on tour
in america now yes well best of luck
with it thank you lovely to see you
thanks for having me nice to see you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well trusted policing is in crisis on
both sides of the atlantic so what do we
do about it on one side a radical fringe
wants to defund the police tear down
those broken institutions as they see it
and start again on the other back the
blue spend strengthen support our cops
defend the police i'm with those but
it's not always easy not when you see
videos not the one i'm about to show you
and warning it is truly shocking this is
shocking security camera footage of the
school massacre in valdez texas where
two teachers and 19 children were shot
dead and it shows craven cowardly police
cowering in the corridor for more than
an hour as the children were slain
inside their classrooms
two minutes later ramos strolls down the
corridor a child turns to run for his
life as the killer opens fire
and just three minutes after that armed
police enter the building
but within 60 seconds they retreat even
as the government continues to fire at
the kids
officers with ballistic shields rifles
and body armor then wait in the corridor
for more than an hour as the massacre
unfolds
one checks his phone
another is seen sanitizing his hands
and at one point sheriff's deputy felix
rubio has to be held back by his own
colleagues
in tears because his own 10 year old
daughter was inside
she died
well finally at 12 50 77 minutes after
the gunman first entered the school
these armed officers eventually
summonsed up the guts to go into that
classroom and kill him but not before 19
children
that kind of policing is impossible to
defend so how do we fix this mess and
restore confidence in the police well
bill bratton is the man to ask he's a
former police chief in both new york and
los angeles as well as an advisor to the
met police here in london josephine bill
great to see you thank you very much for
coming on
good you be with you and your audience i
wanted to start if i may with this
shocking footage has been leaked from
the massacre in
valdez uh we don't normally see this
kind of footage and it's extremely
harrowing but perhaps the most
disturbing part of it is the inaction of
all these armed police what did you make
of it
well it is almost impossible to explain
the unexplainable
we are handicapped in some respects by
looking at
video that's been edited on edited
we don't have the uh the durable aspect
of it the audio
but just what we are looking at
makes you angry extraordinarily angry
particularly as somebody who spent 50
years in the police profession
can't explain it consciously we're not
going to try to justify it there's going
to have to be a lot of
very thorough investigation of what went
wrong there because everything looked
like it went wrong no supervision uh no
coordination no organization
and uh in some instances maybe cowardice
in some instances
bravery that was first exhibited first
officers went down the hall was shot at
but then be treated
it went against everything we trained
for uh in american police
since columbine back in 1989 i think it
was
we train our offices one of you two of
you three of you for you you go to the
danger that's the expectation you take
the oath of office and put that badge on
uh
most of these officers did not go toward
the danger and uh justin right truly
shocking um
on a wider point bill you've i think the
only top policeman to have run the
police in both new york and l.a said
you've been in this game a very long
time and dealt with all sorts of crime
you were famous for the broken window
strategy where you take care of
the lesser crimes in an effort to try
and stem the tide of the more serious
crimes and it was very successful when
you've looked at what's been going on
with crime in america but also in london
you came over here to to try and advise
them the beleaguered met police are
there parallels and what should be done
to restore trust in the police
yeah extraordinary parallels between
british police services and american
police forces uh
the issue of broken windows that uh
while i'm
noted for my support of an
implementation of that strategy dealing
with so-called quality of life
victimless crime uh there's a more
famous individual uh sir robert peel
your first head of the metropolitan
police prime minister and his very
famous nine principles of policing which
is the foundation i stand on the first
one is the basic mission for which
police exist is to prevent crime and
disorder in my country in your country
in the 70s 80s
to the 90s and unfortunately in some
communities even today the emphasis was
strictly on responding to crime it
wasn't believed the police could prevent
it and the focus and prioritization was
serious crime with an almost total
neglect of the so-called broken windows
or quality of life offenses of loitering
public conqueredness graffiti
prostitution the hooligans hanging on
the corner long night long keeping you
awake
my rise in american policing
was i recognized very early on that you
need to focus on both serious crime and
quality of life and why quality of life
is what people see every day and it
might be victimless in the sense you
don't have a specific victim but what is
destroyed on neighborhoods they
deteriorate what is destroyed is
confidence in police and government that
we care on it can be effective the
turnaround of new york city began in the
subways when we started focusing on the
5000 homeless or you
call it sleeping buff uh in our subways
the 250 000 people they're not paying
the fare the aggressive begging the
defeating by focusing on that
divider ship began to feel more secure
based on that success rudy giuliani ivy
1994
interestingly enough
i learned from the metropolitan police
british free services that's where i got
sir robert peel's nine principles sir
robert mark visited boston in 1975 and
met a very impressionable young sergeant
named bill gratton and i married those
nine principals that is the foundation
of
uh young new met commissioner uh uh mark
rawley uh he is really gonna focus on
policing by consent
the reason you call police services in
your country versus police forces in my
country
is this idea that you're there to serve
and service the community and you try to
do that with the minimum force in your
country i applaud and i'm always amazing
quite frankly that the majority of your
officers still vote when it comes to a
vote to not carry firearms because they
feel that will reduce
the confidence that the public has in
them
and the idea that they are a police
service and not a force
it's one of the problems for police both
in america and the uk and indeed
everywhere at the moment that social
media
can very quickly amplify anything it's
very significant but i look at it from
the perspective of plus and minus the
minus is that incidence can be amplified
and magnified uh in a very significant
way
we saw that with george floyd
going back to rodney king back in the
early 90s the first time videotaping
was aired on american television before
social media even occurred and what that
brought about in america uh when i talk
about the plus and the minus the plus
side of it is police can use social
media to their benefit which i certainly
have done in los angeles in new york
with the billions of followers who
access our twitter sites facebook sites
the idea of us telling our story from
our perspective and sometimes with more
facts than the media on social media
might have bill i can talk to you for a
lot longer thank you uh for joining me i
really appreciate it no one has better
credentials about policing than you as
we've just heard so thank you very much
indeed for sparing the time
not the best
ron says up next should you let your
family have a say in your right to die
bake off star dame prulith
thinks
not
yes we would only be having this
conversation when i was within six
months of dying i don't believe that my
son would ruin make my
last six months even more distressing
by
by refusing me that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
great british bake off star dame prulis
is a passionate advocate for assisted
dying which at the moment remains
illegal in britain her son conservative
mp danny kruger completely disagrees he
spoke out recently in parliament against
assisted dying in a debate which was
held after a petition reached a hundred
thousand signatures
over half the people in other countries
where a sister dying is legal choose it
because they feel they're a burden to
their families
tragically a lot also say that they are
lonely isn't this terrible people
getting the state to help to kill them
because they don't want to be a burden
on a family that never visits them
talk to any hospice manager about
relatives and they will quietly confirm
it there are a lot of people who want
granny or grandpa to hurry up and die
well i'm joined now by prue leath lovely
to talk to you
hello pierce
this is a very serious subject and
opinions have been raging on both sides
about it
why do you feel so passionately about
this issue
well i suppose because i'm 82 and
heading for the big decision
um
but i i really i mean i i started
getting interested in the whole subject
when my
um elder brother died and he died a
really horrible death um
and recently my younger brother died and
he
died at home with his family around him
and
he didn't um have assisted suicide
because he didn't need it but he had the
sort of death that i think that
people who want assisted suicide
um would dearly love to have you know
at home their own bed surrounded by
their family what is very interesting
pro is that in many states in america
including california and new jersey
washington vermont um in many of these
states assisted suicide is completely
legal it's legal in many parts of
australia uh it's legal i think in
canada now so there are lots of
countries in the world where assisted
suicide is now
a legal practice and and what's more
it's being um
you know it looks as if um yeah
as if jersey
and scotland will get there before us i
mean it's it's only the uk government
that has been
so
diligent to play devil's advocate for a
moment there are reports out of oregon
for example
where 53 of patients who were helped to
die
gave us a reason that they were a burden
on family friends and carers
rather than citing pain or fear of pain
are you concerned about about that part
of it
yes um i think that first of all i think
it's a legitimate reason um
if you
you know if you know that you are
causing your own your family a lot of
anxiety and anxiousness and and and and
worry about you and you are um
either in huge pain or not enjoying your
life
then um
it's it it's a valid reason i mean i'm
not saying for a minute that
um
that people should
want to commit suicide or
have an assisted death
just because they're about
but being a burden is one of the things
that that is so distressing i mean see
this is where i think that the slippery
slope argument which i think gordon
brown and others have espoused i do
think there is a concern there isn't
there where
you look you're you're you're from a a
lovely family of well-intentioned people
i have no doubt
um however there are lots of families
which perhaps are not quite so well
intentioned to their oldest and not so
dearest um who particularly there's
money perhaps lurking in wills and so on
would be tempted potentially
to really make these people
feel they are a massive burden and
should shuffle off this mortal coil very
sharpish i really think this is a bit of
a bogeyman that doesn't although it does
exist it is quite small one of your sons
he's a tory mp who's actually vehemently
opposed this legislation so what are you
going to do if you decide in a few years
time you've become a massive burden and
he says sorry sorry mum i'm not doing it
well um that's going to be a real
problem because we are devoted to each
other um and he has generally very um
principled um objections i think he's
quite wrong
um but i hope he'll i'm hoping i'll
manage to first of all i'm hoping that
he will not manage to muster all his
mates in parliament to vote against it
and that i will manage to persuade him
before i get there i mean it's a
fascinating situation where your own son
is literally in the house of the
parliament campaigning for the complete
opposite many families have
disagreements about all sorts of things
we happen to have one about this
um but i really think i honestly believe
that it
i should be um in control of my own life
i mean i think the idea that
um
that that somehow human life is is so
sacred i mean sacred to whom it's not
sacred to me and it's my life but you
see okay so here's again though
you think he's like i get it but here's
the thing if i talk to your son about
this i'm sure he'd say well that's fine
that might be her view my mother's view
but actually i love my mother and i
don't want to lose my mother and i want
to get every moment i can out of her and
if she's not in searing agony but is
simply drifting towards the end of her
life i don't want her to be to be
pulling the plug
yes we would only be having this
conversation when i was within six
months of dying i don't believe that my
son would ruin make my
last six months even more distressing
by um
by refusing me that i think he would
argue
i don't want to speak for him but he i
think from the arguments he's put
forward he would probably argue to that
point he would he would say that you're
doing your decision would compound his
distress what about his right to not let
you take your life
no i'm sorry when it comes to my own
life it's my life
[Laughter]
tough he's going to
he's going to lose me within six months
anyway so you know man up and bear it a
few months earlier
really it's a fascinating debate uh not
least your own situation with your own
family uh but unfortunately you're
looking in rude health so we won't have
to encounter this issue i would imagine
for a very long time to come thankfully
but thank you for joining me i
appreciate it
there are so many people who are not in
rude health and we need to think about
them yeah we do a it's an interesting
debate and as you say most of the public
are with you not your son
yeah
great to talk to you
bye-bye
well that's the next it's the big
burning question of our time isn't it
what is a woman well who better to give
us a straight scientific answer than the
world's number one fertility expert lord
robert winston who we've apparently
dragged into the street to give the
answer to this seminal question to speak
to him after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to pittsburgh censored last
week i asked the award-winning singer
macy gray but the woman was she gave me
a simple honest answer which sadly
triggered an avalanche of online abuse
she's branded an ignorant bigot and a
transphobe and eventually went on the
nbc today showing america to backtrack
another church of england struggling
with that question too announcing it has
no official definition of a woman that
additional care is needed when trying to
answer it all very weird well lord
robert winston uh the world leading
scientist in the field of fertility and
reproduction joins me now lord mr first
of all thank you for coming into the
street we've had some logistical issues
and we really appreciate you making the
effort to still do the interview so
thank you
can you answer for me
this very simple question what is a
woman
of course i can't answer the question
anyway a woman is a female and the
female is defined by the genes she has
essentially she has two x chromosomes if
she's human normally and that would be
that would be the
definitive it's probably easier to
define a male a male has specific
masculine genes which make us different
from women and
the the female position is the default
human position that that is to say if
there's no male genes there you're born
as a woman
but i mean dictionaries just simply say
a woman is an adult female and a man is
an adult male 1 why is the world finding
it all so complicated now
it is really quite extraordinary
basically we are a cluster standing here
i'm a clump of about eight trillion
cells at least each of which of those
cells has got my maleness in it i'm
defined genetically every single cell
has got those male genes and that would
apply to a woman who doesn't have those
genes so that what makes the difference
and we cannot escape the fact that we
are
genetically determined in this way of
course they define in terms of shape for
example where they have breasts and all
the rest of it but essentially that's
what it amounts to
so when we have what obviously it's a
complicated debate about uh trans people
for example and as i've regularly said i
i completely support trans people's
rights to fairness and equality
i just have an issue where
you see women's rights get eroded in the
stampede for trans rights and i just
don't think you can create a new
unfairness and equality for example in
in sport and so on
do you think that what we're doing as a
society is conflating
sex and gender which is the point that
jk rowling and others have made strongly
yes piers of course you're absolutely
right and there's no question that we
can change our gender we can do it by
mutilating ourselves we can remove bits
of our body and therefore change our
shape and so on but you can't change
your sex because that is embedded
actually in those genes in every cell in
the body that's the difference and that
really becomes a problem because of
course occasionally you end up with
let's say somebody who is born a male
but then wants to be become a female so
you can have that mutating operation for
example but then the question is should
they be allowed to compete in sport
that's a major problem because of course
they still have certain male
characteristics which will likely give
them an edge over other other other
women and so that is where the problem
really i think lies and of course also
the issue of just social behavior in
different situations using toilets using
bathrooms a whole range of issues like
this which understandably worry women
well i've got a woman here esther kraku
and you're listening to lord winston
he's honestly one of the most eminent
people in this field in the world are
you satisfied with that definition i'm
more than satisfied it physically pains
me that we have to even define what a
woman is because cavemen knew this but
apparently the most educated people in
human history don't know it so you know
thank god he's here to save the day
lord i want to talk to you also about
elon musk he's a fascinating character
but he believes we have a huge
population
problem in the world that actually we
need more people not fewer people do you
agree with him
well you know i think elon musk is a
wonderful individual in what he does but
actually he's not a biologist and let's
just be very clear i don't think it
matters very much because the world's
population will not depend on elon musk
it will not depend on politicians it
will depend on the environment and of
course under the right circumstances the
population will certainly expand
if there is as likely to be starvation
in other parts of the world it will
decrease
what i think we are seeing though is
that rich countries the population is
certainly diminishing but in poorer
countries it isn't because they don't
have the ability to control their births
or they don't have they need more people
to support them in old age for example
and that i think is a fundamental issue
but the world could support a lot more
people if in fact we had better
provision for a whole range of things
like food supplies and so on
are you happy that the political
population of this country
is about to have one less member in
boris johnson
well i don't understand the man frankly
i mean i think he's been
unbelievable it's really difficult to
understand why he insists he wasn't
going to resign for example then of
course finally had to it's very
ignominious and i don't think it's a
great representation of our politics it
is so sad because there are so many
really good politicians around but we
need people actually who have that sense
of actually understanding what the
limits are of what seems to be power i
think for some reason he almost became a
sort of he wanted in his mind a kind of
dictator
this this is an extraordinary thing for
somebody who's a con a conservative who
actually should be conserving the
political arena
yeah i completely agree uh of any of the
runners and riders left in the
leadership race do any of them excite
you can you see yourself being happy
with any of them as prime minister
well you know to tell you the truth i
think this whole uh election process
which the conservative party is going
through is a pretty rubbish contest i
mean how you can choose just two people
out of a pool of 20 or 30 and then put
them in front of another electorate
which also is hand-picked by their
membership of that party doesn't
actually make complete sense it isn't i
think the way a democracy should work
perhaps this can't get sorted out until
finally we have a proper general
election and then we might have some i
think we need to but i think the real
i'm sorry
i could talk to you again a lot longer
and i would love too soon if you don't
mind about to leave it there thank you
very much for your time esther thank you
whatever you're up to keep it
unsensitive good night
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers allen in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big stuff this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams the
five remaining tory leadership
candidates have gone head to head in the
first tv debate of the contest to
replace boris johnson as prime minister
rishi sunak penny morden liz trust kemi
badenock and tom tougenhart all answered
questions from an audience of floating
voters on the channel 4 debate including
on why the public should trust them
their opinion on tax cuts and how they
would make a clean break from boris
johnson
and doctors are urging people to stay
indoors in the coming days as the mess
office issues the highest ever warning
for extreme heat in england there's also
a level 4 national emergency heat health
alert on monday and tuesday with
temperatures potentially reaching up to
40 degrees celsius in some places in the
uk
that's all for now we'll have more news
updates after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign